tomorrow is national happy hour day so
naturally we're helping you plan your
celebration so let's welcome rick here
and chef robert from casa calavera the
culinary cantina inside virgin hotel
welcome guys thank you thank you for
having us oh thank you for being here
and thank you for bringing all of this
because it smells and it looks delicious
so first explain what does the culinary
cantina concept mean sure so casa
calavera is a dia de los muertos
inspired restaurant or day of the dead
which is a holiday that we just
celebrated about a week ago yep yep
that's very cool and what kind of food
are we are we eating here so it's it's
it's all
mexican-based and our happy hour program
is called it's called mikasa sukasa love
that my home is your home yeah
and some of the some of the greatest
hits that we have here are our
guacamoles we have three different types
of guacamole
because that is my favorite the
pomegranate guacamole is my personal
favorite made with mint and green apple
oh that's different and then the spicer
side of life we have a chipotle bacon
guacamole and then the classic as well
oh my gosh that's so good so chef robert
what goes into making this food because
it's not your average you know mexican
cuisine right right right
like this one this is our
avocado and roasted corn taquitos are
vegan taquitos with our homemade roasted
salsa
and then we have the chicken taquitos
it's something
different that we make yeah and we also
we have the tuna tostadas
and you need to try that scene oh i need
oh he says i need to try it so let me go
ahead and try that and rick tell us
about the
happy hours you guys have because
tomorrow is national happy hour day and
we're telling you to go here sure
absolutely so mikasa sukas our happy
hour program at casa calabara we
celebrate daily from three to six p.m uh
and tomorrow we'll be definitely
celebrating for national happy hour day
right oh my gosh
chef robert you were right all of our
entrees are seven dollars of people
spicy though
that's my personal favorite i ordered
that one as a meal oh my gosh that is so
good okay so what's the vibe at costa
calabera like it's what's the energy i
feel it's really chilled and laid back
it's got a it's just got a great
authentic feel it's an indoor and
outdoor restaurant the patio is a great
place right now with the weather just
being perfect perfect great place to
celebrate brunch on sundays which we
also have a brunch program called
lamonian and brunch um we have live
music three nights a week we have the
live mariachi band and friday nights oh
that's amazing we have acoustic music on
sundays and we have a dj on tuesday for
taco tuesday or other culinary holiday
that we celebrate weekly oh you a
culinary holiday that's great you guys
have to have a taco tuesday so coming up
tomorrow why should people come down to
casa calavera to celebrate
national happy hour day well if you're
into celebrating those national culinary
holidays like i am
tomorrow's tomorrow is one of them and a
great time to come down to casa calavera
like i said the perfect the weather is
perfect right now sit outside on the
patio it overlooks the virgin pool
it's it's it's a great time live music
on fridays as well uh that kicks off in
the early evening around 8 p.m with a
live mariachi band
and a great way to start your weekend
off right definitely and it's that
virgin so if you haven't been to virgin
yet you get to kind of kill super at one
stone right absolutely i love it well
you see parkinson's